hi guys I'm Sierra Mira and I'm Maia
Mitchell from good trouble we're here
with BuzzFeed we're gonna play a little
game of would you rather would you
rather have the same crush as your BFF
or be competing for the same job same
job cuz we've I feel like we've
auditioned for the same thing before
that's true
yeah same job else like we work because
we just have the complete opposite we're
like we yeah the same crowd well never
ever yeah same job cuz jobs is like like
if they want you they're never gonna
want me awesome yeah like you know if
you get it that's a victory for me -
yeah they're proud yeah it's true love
you I'm winning - yeah would you rather
be maid of honor and your ex's wedding
or lose all communication with your
closest ex forever
well I would absolutely lose all that
communication I mean I'm sorry I'm too
petty for that - Betty bye-bye
Thank You next would you rather watch
Noah senton AO as a Zeus or Peter K
hazus yeah obviously me Zeus Jesus all
the way the movies cool - he's still are
hazy yes would you rather be able to
tell when anyone's lying or be able to
get away with anyway
oh definitely to be able to tell when
someone's lying I just feel like it
would be too disappointing that would be
awful really
whenever someone lies to you know it I'd
rather not know I'm gonna see I'd like
to wean the real from the fake you know
I'd know my real friends were I'm not
ready for that
would you rather turn bright green every
time you laugh or snort every time you
cry probably snort every time right
because I laugh constantly I would just
be green how laughs is my favorite thing
being about huh she goes like this
that's it yeah it's it's a nice it's
always a knee-slapper you know that's
how you know it's funny
would you rather share an apartment with
an extremely talkative roommate or a
mate who doesn't speak to you at all
when I was like 17 I moved
I went on Craigslist and found like
these three roommates and they were like
35 year old men and I was like 17 and
like trying to live my life and it was
so awkward like I'd try to like talk to
them and they wanted nothing to do with
me and I was all oh yeah so then saw
what we really talked it over me would
you rather go to jail for a crime you
didn't commit
Oh commit a crime and live in fear of
getting caught for the rest of your life
oh definitely commit the crime I don't
know Joe yeah yeah well our crime are we
talking about here are you talking like
Mota or like tax evasion who knows you
gotta live in fear of it which brother
would you rather be stuck on a deserted
island with Brandon hey Zeus or Jude who
would get me there off of the deserted
island I feel like Jude would Brandon
would be useless
Brandon ego would be there for
entertainment yeah I feel like Judah
corn would save the day he'd come
through so Jude so Jude yeah sure what
do you rather land a dream job but never
get acknowledged for your work all work
for a job you hate and constantly get
promoted oh definitely the first dream
job and never get acknowledged I mean it
sounds pretty good at least you're not
really working because it's your dream
job right
would you rather wake up in a new city
every day for a year or wake up in a
random person's body every day for a
week that sounds I'm trying to run out
of pages in my passport so I'll take the
new city every day you should pick that
one every day would be a new adventure I
think it'll be cool to wake up in other
people's what is terrifying I think it
sounds great all right all right would
you rather have your mom's leave
embarrassing comments on all of your
Instagram photos without being able to
delete them or have them post
embarrassing pictures of you but be able
to delete two a month
this is a question view my mom's not on
Instagram my mom's pretty active on
Instagram
very but I love her Instagram her
Instagram you know she does post a lot
of embarrassing pictures of me so I'd
rather take the car I mean although
they're cute yeah but she never asks for
my approval yeah cuz she's a boss
doesn't have to that's true we love you
mama Ram I love you mama Chris but you
rather have a terrible job or a terrible
love life there's one I'd rather have a
terrible job terrible love know that
sounds really sad Oh No thank you I'm
not here for that
not today Satan not today would you
rather never lose your phone again or
never lose your keys again never lose my
phone again I've never been locked out
of your house at night that's nice I
actually Oh I lost my keys once and I
was parked behind someone and I couldn't
find the spare key oh it was a mess
so no would you like to read sorry I
still do it oh right okay would you
rather have a private pool or
super-close beach access beach access
would you rather wear your sisters
clothes for a year or have her borrow
your favorite piece of clothing clothing
once a week for six my good question
this is a great question because I just
me edited together this is I'm waiting
attention we just moved in together and
we're the exact same size but you know
what she's actually so awesome and I
love her style she's very eclectic
I'd rather borrow hers because when she
wears mine she cuts clothes and yeah
makes it her own so I'd rather would you
rather be known as a troublemaker or
goody two-shoes a troublemaker they're
exciting I'd rather be known as a goody
didn't know no one likes a goody
two-shoes I like them would you rather
accidentally sleep with your sister's
boyfriend or find out she slept with an
ex you were madly in love with oh this
is heavy I would definitely yeah the
second one yeah no that's got to be on
you boo sorry you get the last one oh
okay
would you rather go back in time to
change one thing from your past or take
a look at your life five years in the
future I don't want to know what's gonna
happen so I definitely rather go back
and change a few things
some bitmaps karate'd you guys like the
butterfly effect like you could really
drastically change your life just by
changing one thing can I change my
answer
[Laughter]
thank you so much BuzzFeed for having us
that was nice that was fun
yeah I learned a lot about you yes toon
indica trouble on freeform Tuesdays at
8:00 7:00 central
[Music]